bonsoir et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs avec ce soir un invité
exceptionnel c'est le numéro un de
l'organisation en france puisqu'il
s'agirait - du coup du président de la
fédération française des échecs monsieur
jean-claude loubatière au bon soir
président bon ça mais très heureuse
quand mélo et alors tout de suite
actualité c'est évidemment la deuxième
place de shirov autre à monaco et sa
venue prochaine au grand prix de
bordeaux
oui au tournoi exceptionnel donc la
référence au niveau du jeu rapide en
france avec quatre champions shirov
l'écho bauer et le rock racing et le
parrainage d'ailleurs de la fédération
française de fait sur ce tournoi tout de
suite nous rejoignons nous allons
joindre alexei shirov au téléphone et
vous proposez d'une interview du numéro
quatre mondial donc qui vient de
terminer ce second à ce grand tournoi de
monaco derrière qui derrière vladimir
kramnik qui d'ailleurs d'après loire aux
langes la semaine dernière depuis huit
ans en fait tu domines entièrement le
jeu l aveugle à monaco oui c'est vrai
donc en fait c'est annan qui a gagné
dans le jeu rapide et dans le jeu elle
aveugle par contre c'est krasniqi a
gagné qui a gagné dans le container
voilà aulas alex est la star des stars
c'est une des lectrices et chers
internet est un canal web continue pour
téléphoner comme tu as acheté une
tournure intéressante et un monaco
restait seconde où des traces de la
demie panique on analyse dépassionnée
monaco wyatt radio c'est pourquoi donc
je l'aï c'est nous dire nous dit que
c'est plutôt un tournoi d'amusement en
fait oui en fait ça compte pas pour les
lots donc pour lui c'est surtout un
tournoi où il s'entraîne il peut essayer
des choses parce que il ne perd pas de
points elo quoi qu'il arrive donc ça
c'était lui parler de sa prestation
monaco vont essayer de casser y formule
qui n'a pas sabrina et morgane dortmund
était prévu pour priver le concret
castagne le ghana ou du moins trop peu
importe seconde territoire donc nous dit
il est très content
certains comparable à celui de l'année
dernière est donc il était cette année
en bonne forme c'est pour ça que même si
c'était un droit d'entraînement ben il a
eu de bons résultats sans rechercher
forcément tout à fait et il y aura là
l'autorité d'eric scherer forcément
proximité sous participation est
attendue début de bordeaux ce quelque
chose tous des détracteurs d'être
ovationné au château et qui espérait à
faire ici connaissait ce périmètre
univers de couleurs
donc en fait ils espèrent bien battre le
français que ce soit christian bauer ou
laurent frayssinet à la première ronde
et a pris va s'expliquer avec peter des
coûts donc normalement peter les coups
c'est un adversaire qui lui convient
bien
mais enfin bon il est très fort donc on
peut quand même rien dire il faut il
s'agit de jouer la partie
c'est ce qui nous différencie à la
vérité existe quand même sur l'échiquier
yoyo effectivement il nous dit que il
espère bien qu'il va gagner mais c'est
vrai qu'il est archi favori de ce
tournoi avec ses shirov mais que vit
dans tout peut tout peut arriver sur
l'échiquier c'est d'ailleurs tout
l'intérêt du spectacle il y aura au
traitement des tontes et lisa qui va
intéresser aux toros internautes à ce
qu'ils nous connaissent et les stands
mirando slt en dessous de son match
contre kasparov qui sait ce qu'il va
passer pour les employés la transition
oui parce que baba ce match comptera
entre kasparov yankees cuba cette
transaction donc avec c'est sûr on nous
dit que finalement ce match et est
annulé et simon depuis quelques mois
mais que lui en fait tu as toujours
envie de jouer seulement voilà la
question mérite à ma question donc c'est
la gagne est d'ailleurs le droit de
jouer ce match en béton travnik de façon
claire et nette tout à fait et ils moi
je dis il ya un match qui probablement
devoir avoir lieu qui saurait hamas
kasparov à nantes et je demande à
l'excès qui va être sa réaction si t'es
sport finalement joue son match contre
allende en dépit de tout ce qu'il avait
mis en place pour jouer ce match contre
shirov que la situation si c'est un
match mal au final
celui ci si clara donc nous dit que ici
hamas kasparov à nantes ça sera pas
légitime
est ce que cannes on n'a rien gagné
évidemment pour jouer ce match et que ce
soir on peut pas se prétendre champion
du monde comme ça et choisir son
adversaire advitam eternam
un petit peu donc ça serait évidemment
un masque humain qu aurait sûrement de
légitimité ces gars là mondiale à las
vegas
dos santos est ce que c est pour se
poster au garde-à-vous charih tôt à
l'issue d'un arrêt qui veulent connaître
et ce parce qu'il ya la construction
était série à hamas ils peuvent tenter
par à tout seul quand on demande aux as
bégard au ghana contrat kasparov et au
quai de gare à la casse pas les syriens
ne sont pas réunies pour que patrice
yung remorque s'est moqué épouse yvonne
opposés s'attirent comme le monde pour y
explorer et donc sur la question venant
porter sur sur sa participation las
vegas à l'exception confirme le fait qui
va effectivement essayé 20 jouer le
championnat du monde de las vegas pour
lui ces deux choses différentes donc de
jouer comme kasparov ou d'aller jouer à
las vegas que les deux shows sont aussi
importantes peut-être plus à las vegas
ce serait plus officielle
et que c'est pas son problème si
kasparov lui refuse d'aller jouer à las
vegas en gros je résume c'est à peu près
ça que nous a dit alekseï et voilà qu'au
quai mavia zito à l'excès qu'il donne
une machine pour tenter qui dispose de
bolduc les barques ou la sérotonine
sarajevo non donc oui on est dans un jeu
si tu as moins importante et paradis
allemands 6 cycles à wroclaw
donc je parle et agit rapidement son
prochain tournoi importe très important
évidemment après après bordeaux c'est un
tournant à sarajevo où il y aura
kasparov et chroniques et qu' il va il
se prépare vraiment très fortement pour
démontrer le monde des échecs avec la
présence de kasparov sur ce tournant la
queue mais il est là et bien là et que
et qu'il a bien mérité de jouer son
match contre kasparov
donc ça va le prouver aussi au monde qui
effectivement kasparov quand il dit que
j rock n'est pas le challenger valable
bien il veut bien sûr montrer deux
compères au monde des échecs
mon intérêt le thé aux déchets ou clara
damico laraque et de conciliation
réfutable nous venons à sarajevo il
tombe bien il termine par une bourde et
proxim moyenne dans ses démonstrations
alexei pour tous c'est une triste à un
canal web unique à l'honneur il ya ce
talent installation à proxim adios voilà
donc petite interview d'alexei shirov
qui confiant qui peut se conserver
donc il est évidemment déçu ça sent que
ce match contre kasparov et été annulés
je crois qu'il faut rappeler quand même
ce qui s'est passé dans ce match en fait
il a joué un match contre cram nique et
le vainqueur n'avait pratiquement pas de
prix le prix c'était la qualification
pour jouer contre kasparov
or donc tu peux amener de la voilà ce
match comme kasparov n'ayant pas eu du
s'était il est vraiment lésés de façon
incroyable comme jamais céder c'est
arrivé dans le monde des échecs là donc
effectivement il a de quoi
quand même se plaindre et puis avoir un
peu la rage au coeur mais je crois qu'il
va il a vraiment à coeur de je pense
qu'il va être très remonté je pense que
le ton à sarajevo
on va avoir un investisseur très remonté
on avait vu une prestation nice et
shirov avec anzhi
mais moi j'avais le sentiment quand même
qu'il avait il y avait un peu freiné son
jeu parce que pour lui il avait encore
une possibilité d'organiser le match
puisqu'il était encore en négociations à
barcelone je crois est à mon avis n'a
pas livré il n'a pas livré son vrai jeu
parce qu'il gardait si préparation je
pense qu'à sarrio il va vraiment se
lâcher et on va voir du très grand
cherokee oui puis elle titre de champion
du monde à las vegas qui est aussi un
âge qui suit un traitement important
parce que ce sera deux champions du
monde officiel je crois que quoi qu'il
arrive
oui tout à fait après autant d'années
disons d'attentes pour un vrai
championnat du monde
las vegas le champion qui va sortir la
liga sera une grande grande légitimité
façon il y aura probablement cram nick
également les chroniques qui n'avait pas
joué l'année dernière et qui l'iphone
n'a plus de raison de ne pas jouer voilà
la raison il n'avait pas joué parce que
karpov aller directement en finale et
donc lui considéré comme la plupart des
joueurs d'échecs du monde que ce n'était
évidemment pas normal donc voilà
effectivement voilà voilà pour ce pour
ce petit dossier shiro donc on était
très content d'avoir d'avoir une petite
entrevue du quatrième joueur mondial ici
sur diagonale
donc j'espère que ça vous à vous
intéresser pour savoir quelle était la
position de ce joueur qui avait acquis
le droit donc de jouer un match
championne du monde comme kasparov et
qui sera donc à présent présent à
bordeaux la semaine prochaine d'ailleurs
je vous signale que le jeudi 8 avril à
18 heures en direct sur canal fnac qui
est disponible depuis canal web ou sur
canal fnac sur le site de la fnac
pendant une heure les quatre champions
du grand prix de bordeaux shirov l'écho
bauer et freyssinet seront devant du
public et des journalistes donc pour une
heure de train retransmission sur
internet
voilà pour cette pour cette information
on va continuer avec la naissance donc
du site internet de la fédération cite
attendu par beaucoup de monde et
j'aurais qui remplit vraiment je crois
que tout le monde est content de ce site
moi j'étais surpris le week-end dernier
j'étais allé voir un match de
championnat régional à bordeaux
de nationale 3 en fin de match bon sens
sans importance particulière du genre de
match habituel
le soir même à minuit le site de la
fédération étaient à jour avec les
résultats et c'était vraiment agréable à
voir
ouais tout à fait donc en fait c'est que
quand même ce qui se passait avec le
minitel jusqu'à présent maintenant c'est
sur internet et donc ça une diffusion
encore plus large et donc tous des tous
les amateurs qui jouent le dimanche le
soir peuvent avoir le résultat complet
et puis le classement de leur groupe
donc ça fait partie ça va encore une
fois communiquer la passion des échecs
c'est essentiel pour l'information et
avec une adresse évidemment que tout le
monde va chercher parce que la
fédération française
c'est la première chose qu'on va essayer
de charger sur internet c'est que si on
s'intéresse un tant soit peu aux échecs
de près ou de loin un jour ou l'autre on
va on va vraiment aller sur ce site
oui ok qu'elle va être là le contenu de
ce site il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
font doubler tous les affiliés ont ayant
absolument donc tous les affiliés à la
fédération en soldes sur angers par club
leur classement leur classement elo
rapide leur code et donc on peut savoir
donc qui joue dans quelques heures ça c
est donc ce à tous les joueurs peuvent
la voir tout de suite on peut savoir où
est ce qu'il y à des clubs en france
partout avec la magie avec l'adresse du
correspondant les heures d'ouverture et
puis c'est un ca jour dix ans s'est mis
à jour une fois par semaine pas avec la
seric montréjeau croit la fessée eric
boury qui a fait un travail remarquable
sur ce quoi et qui travaille maintenant
on continue parce que deux c'est un
début évidemment il ya aussi le
rejoindre à des grands tournois puisque
tout à fait on peut voir les parties
d'un bien par exemple puis surtout aussi
il ya énormément de parties de jouées en
france qui sont qu'ils sont
nulle part ailleurs et qui s'en
donnaient là d'anglais joueurs peuvent
effectivement avoir des parties de
nationale 3 de partie de ça c'est très
intéressant les joueurs de clubs
peut-être pour mieux se préparer pour
jouer contre tel ou tel joueur à grâce
au souci de la fédération en trouvant
des parties d'un adversaire qui se
trouveront nulle part ailleurs
oui je crois que dans qu'il y a un côté
qui intéresse plus spécifiquement le
joueur des clubs particulier ya aussi
tous les règlements et fédéraux qui
jusqu'à présent était donnée bien sûr
envoyé gratuitement dans lesquels
maintenant chaque joueur peut consulter
tous les règlements de la fédération
tous trop d'articles petit article 2 du
championnat de france des clubs que ce
soit de la coupe de la fondation tout
est accessible sur internet
donc ça c'est un volet l'autre volet
c'est le volet l'ouverture sur le grand
public qui est quelque chose de très
important puisque maintenant c'est un
immense champ d'action qui s'ouvre le
monde d'internet qui est un monde en
évolution et des échecs qui sont pas
tout neuf puisque c'est quand même un
jeu qui date d'une quinzaine d'une
quinzaine de siècle
ben les échecs en fait on une place
particulière parce que parce que
normalement ils sont très ancrés
évidemment oui mais aussi en par les
échecs par internet on peut faire des
choses qu'on peut pas faire ailleurs
d'abord on peut jouer bon non le site un
amateur de foot bien il pourra pas jouer
au foot sur internet
bon alors que sur internet on peut jouer
aux échecs contre des gens du monde
entier faire des trois n'importe quelle
heure de la nuit fera des tournois qui
seront pour l'instant des parties libres
mais certainement du tournoi
officiellement net ça c'est clair
la fédération va organiser des
championnats de france individuels et
par équipes sur internet ça ça va
arriver et demi pourquoi pas aussi
rapide bien d'autres les joueurs sur une
jeunesse aime beaucoup jouer les pluies
et puis donc
il y a les spectateurs un des
spectateurs du monde entier qui peut
aussi on peut suivre à la fois effectué
on peut jouer mais on s'est intéressés
pour suivre une partie d'entre eux
suivent la partie crois que ça c'est dix
ans les parties d'un champion de france
des clubs sur sur internet à une cadence
rapide que ce soit 20 minutes par joueur
ou quelque chose comme ça aurait un
public fou quoi de plus il faut oui je
crois que ça va ça a vraiment attiré ça
va vraiment attiré du monde ça attire
déjà du monde toutes les tous les sites
plus ou institutionnels qui existait
déjà sur le net ont tout de suite réagi
à la création de ce site avec avec donc
une action très positive en mettant les
liens et en disant que c'était vraiment
un site très complet
donc on rejette évidemment longue vie et
on suppose que ça va être ce site qui va
sûrement retransmettre les prochains
championnats de france en août qui sont
donc à besançon voilà par internet
effectivement donc à besançon dans des
conditions exceptionnelles des salles de
jeu est remarquable
et puis la formule a été dynamisée ça
veut dire jusqu'à présent le national
c'était 16 joueurs qui seront compris
tous mais comme c'était un tournoi tout
rond disons à la dernière ronde parfois
mal et les jeux étaient déjà faits ouais
donc ça allait pas crescendo or
maintenant on a fait deux groupes de
huit qui vont se rencontrer
et puis il va y avoir de demi finales et
finales donc 120 jeunes héros plus voilà
plus dynamique plus plus spectaculaire
est est ce qu'on pourrait appeler ça une
indication sur la somme des prix qui
sont données pour un championnat de
france par exemple qu'un tournoi machine
pourtant c'est 220 mille francs de ça de
pris pour les joueurs de sam raimi pour
les seize pas parler pour les 16 la
moitié 110 mille pour cent dix mille
francs de prix pour les seize joueurs du
national ce qu'on appelle nationale il
ya aussi 110 mille francs de prix pour
le tour - qui sont autour voilà tous les
gens peuvent venir
jouer il ya un prix uniquement
évidemment pris ce qui priverait pas du
budget global de la moyennisation ce que
je ressens mais sinon il ya 850 entre
850 et 900 joueurs qui sont là pendant
deux semaines pour ces championnats de
france
oui je sais pas si on a déjà battu la
barre des 1000
non on n'a pas battu mais ça va pas
tarder j'observais ça va y arriver et
parcours qui était normal de grande
participation sur un sport quand même à
la fois c'est vrai concentré sur quinze
jours c'est ça qui est intéressant mais
donc il y à un peut-être battre la balle
barre des 1000 ha aux championnats de
france des jeunes qui va se dérouler à
romans dans quelques jours donc du 10 au
18 avril
immédiatement après le grand prix de
bordeaux donc laurent frayssinet par
exemple va quitter la lorraine facile
tout jeune 6 à 17 ans donc il encore
qualifiable pour les championnats de
france juniors évidemment qualifié et
maître international c'est un des plus
grands espoirs de france avec tes
troisième macro est grand plus de
bordeaux dans la foulée effectivement il
va au championnat de france des jeunes
ce qui fait beaucoup de travail pour
laurent frayssinet c'est la semil et
près de 1000 km entre 6 et 20 ans qui
sont eux qualifiés c'est un tournoi open
ils doivent être qualifiés par leurs
championnats dans leur région dans leurs
départements etc
mais c'est un événement voilà donc un
événement s'échapper la france donc des
jeunes championnat
donc de france toutes catégories à
besoins sont très importants et tout ça
suivi maintenant avec le site internet
de la fédération ce qui va être une
source très intéressante pour les pour
tous les joueurs de clubs et même aux
autres les gens qui vont s'intéresser de
près ou de loin un petit peu la vie des
échecs en france en tout cas
donc voila voila pour ce site on va
passer maintenant à une autre partie du
jour on a décidé donc j'ai choisi donc
partie la dernière ronde qui est une
partie de
donc de vladimir kramnik donc le
vainqueur contre joël lautier donc une
partie très intéressante qui fait moins
de trente coups qui s'arrête au 24e coup
et comme à suivre maintenant donc avec
vous en direct avec donc des
commentaires du président de la
fédération donc c'est quand même un
petit duc se conçoit en s'offre ce soir
président de la fédération qui est aussi
un bon joueur vous avez un bon
classement vous avez c'est même joué
dimanche avec mon club le plus grand
notre classement est de 1210 donc de 810
est déjà un classement qui est
international vous êtes apte à jouer des
tournois internationaux
malheureusement j'ai pas le temps où
elle était là on peut difficilement
faire
donc voilà cette partie vous pouvez
suivre avec nous cette partie donc sur
votre droite vous avez la possibilité de
cliquer sur une petite icône il a écrit
jouer et vous rentrez sur un applet java
qui vous propose la même partie que nous
allons analyser
maintenant avec vous sur l'écran vidéo
voilà partis donc vladimir kramnik
contre joël lautier donc la lumière
cranie je rappelle qu'ils numéro trois
mondial et joël aux tic est notre numéro
un français récent vainqueur du tournoi
d'enghien j'ai déjà été dans les 20
meilleurs du monde qui a une petite une
année un peu difficile mais qui va
revenir très fort cette année et qu'ils
ont fait un très bon tournoi monaco qui
a aussi fait un très bon tournoi mon
impôt on va voir tout de suite cette
partie là des mécaniques contre joël
lautier
alors voilà vladimir démarre avec une
ouverture qui va être relativement donc
classique avec cavaliers f3 qui est un
coup classique et joël lautier répond
par une occupation du centre avec le
coup un dessin qu'on va passer sur les
premiers coups que les deux joueurs
connaissent bien et s'arrêter au moment
peut-être la position de demander un peu
plus d'explications et occupation du
centre sur ce coup des cinq de joël
lautier vladimir kramnik réplique par
l'occupation symétrique deuxième coup
des noirs 7,6 ou classique encore une
fois une solidification de sa rentrée
protège le groupe des 5 et permet à ce
fou f8 de pouvoir sortir la dernière
chronique répond par une contre attaque
centrale ici tout de suite mettant une
pression au centre avec ce coup sekkat
souvent joué dans ses titres
arthur instaurant une tension ici entre
c'est entre ces deux pions je vais
lautier choisi de prendre tout de suite
ce pion donc là on peut peut-être ont
recommandé que on a la possibilité aussi
de ne pas prendre ce pion bien sûr et
met donc je vais le dire accepter les
gambeat quoi puisque c'est un beat dance
allez les blancs on donnait un pion le
pion c4 est bon il ils vont pendant ce
temps se développer et gagner de
l'espace
et puis il espère reprendre le pire un
petit peu plus tard dans de bonnes
conditions
alors voyons comment kramnik répond par
la prise de ses pions mais tout
simplement par le coup très simple deux
trois qui libère le fouet fin ici sur le
pion c4 justement et du blanc vont très
rapidement pouvoir récupérer soutien
probablement je vais d'ailleurs ne
s'accroche pas opinion cavalia si son
coût de développement tranquille la
ville a dit mercredi récupère le pion
sacrifier facile et en développant une
pièce toujours un principe aux échecs
développer rapidement ses pièces et
ensuite pouvoir éventuellement
rapidement aux six mètres sont rois à
l'abri donc là je vais lautier besoin de
coups intéressants
25 c'est là qu'on pratique sur le
sambrien
depuis on sait cinq attaques les pilotes
des quatre
bon les les
les blancs j'ai pas eu la partie donc je
sais pas j'ai regardé peuvent à la
partie mais de même coup logique de
contre attaque le saut pions c5
c'est un petit peu symétrique d'ailleurs
puisque les blancs avaient attaqué avec
ce pion c4 à cause des cinq les noirs
bon effectivement on fait un petit peu
la même chose protégé par le fouet fuit
depuis on ne risque rien mais il
instaure une tension centrale te fais
toujours bien dont les blancs a priori
n'ont pas intérêt à prendre le pion c5
puisque sinon les noirs et changerait
les dames donc s'il vous en prenez par
exemple dans ces cinq dames foundem donc
la dame pourrait prendre avec échec leur
offre en cadeau du roi qui est le roi
serait des rockets donc voila c'était un
petit désavantage imola le roi ayant
bougé il n'a plus droit au fameux coup
du rock qui permet de jouer de leroy 2
casey de mètres la tour de m donc le roi
à l'abri derrière ses pions tout en
mettant en jeu la tour il faudrait la
laisser en droit qui centralise et qu'il
serait sujet à l'attack des pièces
ennemis alors donc la dîmière kramnik
mais évidemment refuse de la plus de ses
pions et joues la dame en sur une case
en e2 ou après un échange de noir par
exemple
évidemment les plans les blancs pour
reprendre du pied droit et libérer ainsi
l'action de la dame sur 7 sur 7 semi
colonnes ici avec une action
intéressante dans aussi protège le four
accessoirement donc une case de
développement classique aussi pour cette
dame dans ce type de ce type de position
là joël loti choisit maintenant de
prendre quand même au niveau central
donc sur la case des 4 et la bladimir
kramnik effectivement reprend du pied
aux trois dont gardant un pion central
des avantages peut être que les
avantages et inconvénients
ça libère l'espace mais y accueillons
tout seul est un pion qui est isolé ce
qu'on appelle un pion isolé c'est à dire
il n'est pas soutenu par une autre pion
donc il est plus facilement attaquable
et c'est un objectif d' attaque
voilà où un camion blanc n'est présent
ni sur la colonne c'est ici sur cette
colonne donc abaissé ici pas de pions
blancs et sur la colonne ou et le roi
non plus pas de pions blancs donc ce
pion ne peut défendu que par des pièces
c'est le désavantage ce type depuis ont
par contre on dit souvent que ça donc
plus de
berthe et aux pièces puisque tout de
suite presque fou peut jouer on a une
case ans le 5 ici sur lequel peut sauter
le cavalier donc des coûts intéressants
pour les blancs d'oeufs de développement
donc voyons maintenant la réaction des
noirs donc jouer l'outil jouer un coup
très simple de développement le fou et
c'est faux vous à permettre tout de
suite de mettre le roi noir
à l'abri derrière ses pions fagniérot
kramnik fait de même petit rock donc
huitième coup des blancs petit rock on
met le roi à l'abri on amène une tour en
développement c'est tout jusqu'à présent
en fait c'est découvrement logique aux
agences et ce qu'il faut c'est tout à
fait un développement des pièces rapide
il on va dire contrôle du centre on met
des pions sentent souvent c'est de
contrôler le centre ont contre attaque
le centre faut éviter de laisser
l'adversaire s'installer au centre trop
longtemps puisque ça lui donne une
domination des espaces souvent qui est
souvent gênantes donc il faut pas
laisser le centre adverse s'installer
durablement donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
vu ses contre attaques à la fois
blanches et noires sur le centre dans le
centre et c'est l'espace le plus
important de l'échiquier donc il faut
conquérir les centres s'y installer et
donc il ya une lutte justement peau pour
savoir qui va être le maître du centre
pour l'instant donc a priori si les
blancs que l'on peut mettre du sens
grâce à ce pion qui est central au
contrôle comme sur noir plus de liberté
d'un homme mais ce pion peut s'avérer
plus tard une faiblesse faiblesse pour
les noirs donc il ya des avantages
évidemment et des inconvénients
là je vais loti choisi de ne pas re ok
tout de suite mais de sortir une pièce
qui encore une fois que les attaques le
pur latex cette fois-ci clairement les
pions puisque donc il peut le prendre
peut prendre le pion de décathlon qui
menace le lotier menace maintenant de
prendre en d4
et si les blancs reprenez le cavalier
tout de suite la dame prendrait avec
genk gand les blancs n'ayant pas de
d'attac immédiate alors à leur
disposition donc faut que vladimir
kramnik fasse attention il n'en a pas
perdre ce pion central très important
sans compensation qui choisit tout
simplement de protéger parce koudou
l'intérêt du rock c'est là on va aussi
un désintérêt du rock
le roi est à l'abri mais aussi la
tourette rentrant j'ai tout de suite
rentrer en jeu et elle soutient le pion
qui peut à tout moment maintenant
proposer une poussée soutenu par la tour
et le fou qui pourrait s'avérer
difficile à négocier pour les bleus pour
les noirs un enfant le petit robe
tranquillement mais eux aussi le roi à
l'abri et sept tours plus tard canada
mort à bouger pour elle-même s'opposer
sur cette colonne et continuer la
pression qui s'installent ici sur sur le
sur le centre bladimir kramnik sort
lui-même ses pièces voyez que les
joueurs en fait c'est presque naturel
voilà aussi ce jeu se sont du coup
naturelles développement ils se pressent
pas engager une action
on voit souvent ailleurs des amateurs
j'ai noté souvent ici d'engager des
actions de jeu trop tôt et c'est
sûrement gtc c'est le défaut des
débutants peuvent attaquer tout de suite
au lieu de se développer de sortir leurs
pièces donc évidemment à ce niveau là un
ipod fois l'heure ils savent très bien
qu'il faut il vaut mieux avoir des
pièces qu'ils soient le plus actif
possible que d'essayer de faire des
attaques qui sont pas bien préparés
donc là on remarquera que les blancs
ressenti presque toutes leurs pièces mme
plus que le fou à sortir sur une case en
trois ans j'ai cinq peut-être un f4
beaucoup de possibilités pour ce fou la
deuxième tour pourrait venir anciens il
aurait fini leur développement ils
pourraient apprécié à des actions plus
plus efficace toutes leurs pièces ayant
un maximum de potentialités alors voyons
maintenant comment les noirs jouent donc
là les noirs choisi d'attaquer le fou c4
avec ce coup que la veille à 5 qui
propose de prendre ce fou ce qui serait
pas forcément une bonne opération pour
les blancs
parce qu'un échange donc qu'elle valait
prend fou d'un prof ou est ce parce que
l'avenir kramnik peut permettre ce type
de d'échangés non parce que
le faux blanc est un est une pièce très
très active à la diagonale blanche qui
était très forte ici est donc ce fou et
fort donc ce fou pour poster ici aurait
une action à la dent qui pourrait être
dangereux a priori pas les changer donc
le président du conseil ne pas laisser
le foncier en prix en général dit
souvent d'ailleurs quand fu est un petit
peu plus fort qu'on cavalli un tout
petit peu surtout dans l'est dans les
finales surtout comme les deux fous
sommes plus forts qu'eux que fout et
cavaliers ou que deux cavaliers dans la
queue mais il y a des positions il ya
des bons fous et des mots et faut donc
dans certaines positions
le fou est mauvais parce que les pièces
en les pions surtout son nom placés de
telle sorte que le fou nappe a très peu
d'action et parfois le fou est bon et
donc il faut pas d'échangé sans souvent
on dit on va peut-être parler de ce
thème là parce que c'est vraiment un
thème là de la partie qui se joue parce
que donc je vais le type propose cet
échange est souvent on sait pas mais il
faut il changer ou pas cette pièce un
truc général aussi qu'on dit a montré
qu'on le règle générale que l'on dit
aussi c'est l'écart les son plus fort
quand les pions sont à une brique et un
petit peu ses repères les pyogenes en
fait le déplacement des pièces à longue
portée ce que karl il va falloir se
glisser dans l'est dans les interstices
un petit peu alors tout affairé fait le
fou ou même des espaces libres le
cavalier lui
il veut un petit peu partout ils sont un
peu partout alors que ce que fait la
démarche kramnik évidemment voilà
l'annuaire crâne il refuse cet échange
et il met son s'en fout on notera aussi
que le fou peut venir là bas il n'y a
plus la possibilité pour le nord de
prendre ce pion des quatre puisque le
cavalia bouger notamment
il y avait la tour aussi finalement qui
protégeait mais encore plus maintenant
que le câble est à la bande le fouet
tranquillement placé en b3 en d3 sur
cette case control en diagonale très
longue et qui a des visées déjà vers le
roi noir donc qui peut s'avérer
dangereux au lait noir joue beaucoup
simple bessette b6 qui permettra de
placer ce fou noir ici sur une case
intéressante ambitieux puisqu'il
consolera une grande diagonale il aurait
pu jouer aussi le coup fou dès cet été
pour le moins efficace
certainement la bonne place du fossé
c'est effectivement un bébé c'est parce
que la dame toujours comme ça c'est tout
cette quasi voilà tout à fait oui c'est
vrai et donc sinon la dame comme ça a
continué à regarder avec attention des 4
et vit à londres mais effectivement si
le foot est venu en dix-sept ici la dame
ne contrôlerait plus ce qui se passe ici
au centre et ça pourrait être un thème
de combinaisons donc d'où l'idée de
l'enseignement marquera aussi non
seulement ça permet une bonne case bilan
sur le faux billets et si ça protège ce
cavalier ça protège d'écueils contrôler
la lingerie effectivement donc d'un
certaine
et puis aussi la science a là il
retrouve à l'essai libérez-les à la
bonne place pour la tour noire c'est
évidemment la tour c'est de venir ici en
ses 8,7 3,8 sur cette colo voilà ouverte
une fois que fourrage enlever cette idée
pour les noirs c'est de mettre leur tour
ici contrôle à un signe colonna ayant
une action dans le camp blanc alors que
le tour en 1 8 n'a aucune action dans le
camp blanc elle est bouchée par son
propre pions
elle va pouvoir par contre très vite
venir sur cette case alors est ce que
fait de manière chronique maintenant il
sort juste une pièce qui ne jouaient pas
ce fou maintenant instaurant une
une tension déjà sur ce cavalier
enrichissent proposant éventuellement
d'un certaine variante un échange ici on
notera que ce cavalier 6 protège la case
h77 cassis qui est attaqué par ce fou
donc ce coup fourré saint castor ou
indirectement une menace de tensions
supplémentaires sur cette case
on pourrait imaginer que par exemple si
les blancs prennent un f6 les noirs
reprennent et après par exemple coup
dame eu quatre ans menace de veut faire
d'un proche est protégé par le fou et on
attaque réussie la torah 8 ça pourrait
être une menace tout de suite des blancs
c'est une semaine sans cavalier faut
prendre cavaliers dames 4 protégé par le
four menace d'un proche cet échec et mat
faut parer ce math par exemple à jouer
un g7 g6 mais la up
la dame attaques créent aussi la tour ça
serait une fourchette une sorte de
revanche est en fait allusion
attention un jeu de la taille de houblon
et ce même si on était à côté de lui on
me dirait on essaierait de glisser seul
inconvénient c'est que en fait le coup
naturelles dont on a parlé foot 17 par
la menace je vais loti joue tout
simplement laissé tomber cette et la
dame ne pourra plus jamais maintenant
venir sur cette case contrôlée par ce
fou et la tourte tout de suite et non
seulement un protégé par le fou par la
dame et pourra venir suit donc la
combinaison ne fonctionne plus donc pas
rendre plus simple de développement je
le type par cette cette menace de
vladimir kramnik maintenant vladimir
kramnik profitent alors ça c'est
intéressant à noter ce coût ce que c'est
un coup intéressant puisque le clavier
au centre donc à une bonne action
dans le camp adverse il est protégé par
ce pion des 4 par contre on peut se
poser la question attention oui mais
maintenant que ce que la bougie ne
protège plus le pion des quatre donc par
exemple et noir pourrait faire d'armes
prend pioneer bien sûr j'ai pourquoi
alors voilà pourquoi c'est pas possible
allez les noir et blanc un jour est fou
prendre pied en échec auront donc le roi
serait donc obligés par exemple de
prendre le fou sur cet échec il le
pourrait aussi jouer ensuite aidé à tout
reprendre et la dame
voilà donc les loueurs en faisant cet
échec aurait libéré l'action de la tour
et donc la dame serait perdu donc c'est
un piège classique voilà c'est un piège
classique
donc attention le bolivien au centre les
noirs ne peuvent pas prendre le pion à
du fou prend h7 roi prend acheter par
exemple
et après tout reprendre la dame donc si
un petit piège que vont être contents
chronique reigning n'espérez pas que je
le tiens elle est tombée dans le piège
mais surtout en plus c'est une bonne
place pour le cavalier 1 700 gardien une
bonne case sens sans inconvénient qui
fait pression un petit peu d'encre noire
contrôle des gaz qui peuvent être g co
présideront notamment f7 pourrait être
une cible plus tard sa troupe de cavale
est envisageable
beaucoup de choses donc il faut faire
attention dans la joie lautier
tranquillement mais il choisit de mettre
maintenant lui aussi sa tour en jeu donc
développer si ces pièces se tourne
maintenant contrôler cette colonne est
mieux placé ici quant à 8 tout
simplement l'aplanir kramnik choisi lui
aussi maintenant de sortir sa tour et là
on peut dire que le développement des
deux camps et total est terminée tout à
fait oui il va falloir maintenant
trouver qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
une position comme ça où toutes les
pièces sont développées bon les blancs
quand même
des petits avantages d'espacé d'abord
donc leurs deux tours sont mobilisés
alors qu'il ya une tour en fuite qui est
qui et puis tout s'est tous dit corps
qui n'a qu'un rôle passif défensif plus
on dira qu'on approche du roi de défense
il a ensuite il ya un cavalier qui est
sur l'avant-poste de 5 ha et qui donc
menace le camp adverse
ensuite il y à un flou qui est qui et
quand même très très dangereux quoique
le trou noir pour les choses en noir aux
603 le doyen effectivement je voudrais
bien placé son fou puisqu'il contrôle
une case d'angers 2 qui pourrait
s'avérer dangereuse pour les imagine ont
des possibilités pour la dame de venir
en d5 si ce cavalier là n'était plus là
par exemple et en dessin que la madame
menacerait tout simplement d'un projet
de tce climat'' donc ça peut être un
thème dans la partie et il faut faire
attention évidemment pour le camp blanc
aussi donc on peut dire que le
développement des deux camps était
harmonieux avec un thème donc de
domination centrale un petit peu pour
les blancs avec ce pion qui l'avantagent
champions que ses protégés bien ce
cavalier il peut servir de pousser de
levier au centre général quand on est
comme ça c'est effectivement on a envie
de le pousser à un moment donné il faut
à le pousser pour exploiter davantage
l'intérêt de nos suppositions le plan ça
peut être de se dire il faut échanger un
maximum de pièces pour enlever les
potentialités et attaques des blancs et
après et après look et ses pions pour
essayer de le prendre et finalement
avait contacté sur les points faibles
voilà et j'ai dit mobilisé les blancs la
défense de ce pion essaie de capturer
peut-être et après gagner une finale
avec un point de plus voilà voilà l'idée
que pour les morts dont 15 pour les
et pour les noirs le coup part dans 14
pour les noirs le coup cavaliers des
cinq qui répond un petit peu cet
objectif bloc le pion ici est par contre
proposé un échange ici un échange du cou
noir 7 contre le fu g5 alors que fais tu
l'as dit mercredi qu il ait choisi de
menacer tout de suite avec saddam il
choisit de ne pas prendre le fou ici en
7 mai de venir avec la dame hct menacé
tout simplement d'un proche cet échec et
mat puisqu'ils se la dame serait protégé
par le fou et ce coup il possible parce
que les noirs jouent le coup que la
vallée des saints mais coeur donc là il
faut voir l'ensemble de la gueule de la
combinaison parce que il faut avoir
calculé parce que sinon ma sinon les
lignes les les glandes perdrait une
pièce bien sûr parce que on ne peut
paraît assez facilement
alors voilà c'est ce qu'a dit le
président qui est un peu effectivement
enfin sonore un peu compliqué c'est que
effectivement aux menaces m'a tout de
suite mais les noirs peuvent se défendre
par le coup simple g7 g6 et si par
exemple donc maintenant la dame rouge
par exemple en h36 les le jeu de me fout
les cinq est attaqué par le fossé est
protégé par la dame 7
donc c'est très dangereux les noirs
gagné une pièce d nord gagnait une pièce
sur je sais les six la dame de obligé de
bouger à prix fous prend fou ghanem
pièces pour les
pour les noirs alors qu'a prévu la
nouvelle chronique alors peut-être une
possibilité sur g7 g6 c'est pour les
blancs de prendre d'abord en fait c'est
une effectivement parce que si donc
j'essaye g6 pour le noir par exemple
vous prendre sept et six lignes noires
prenez la dame évident mais le fond
blanc prendre lui-même son homologue
noir est et nord serait obligé de
reprendre du pillon ce qui serait pas
très bon pour la défense de leurs droits
après donc et on aurait au final un
échange fou et dames les charges de fou
et ensuite annie charland puisque les
noirs reprendrait le fou la fin de la
variante donc je refais cette vente pour
pour que vous voyez g7 g6 pour parer la
menace des blancs pourraient faire donc
si la dame joue le fou ou g5 et perdu à
cause de fawcett prendre g5 protégé par
la danois donc j'essaie jesse ce fou
prend 1,7 pour éviter la perte de pièces
les noirs si noir maintenant prenez la
dame blanche en h5 vous prendre dames et
après tout reprend dame y aurait eu
échange de dames est de fous des deux
côtés avec les noirs avec un pion h5 ici
au final qui serait pas très bon
ce qui devrait casser à la la défense du
roi noir or les noirs aussi foufou
prendre 7 pourrait choisir tout
simplement de reprendre le fonds eco
avait les qualités ou avec lecavalier et
ensuite la dame serait obligé de bouger
donc attention il ya quand même des
possibilités dans cette position donc il
faut que je vais lautié
calcule bien tout ça et sachent à quoi
s'en tenir pour pâris et menace les
noirs peuvent aussi parer à la menace en
achète en jouant le coup h et 7 h 10
mais qui paraît sujet disons inciter des
blancs à sacrifier du matériel cercle et
blanc pourrait prendre en jce avait levé
sur la reprise après la dame prend fou
plus d'âme avec des menaces de maths on
aurait donné une pièce mais avait des
menaces très difficile à paris donc que
fait jouer lautié ben ils jouent le coup
g7 g6 qui alors le plus solide et
maintenant faut que vladimir kramnik
fasse attention s'ils jouent saddam tout
de suite hyper le fou donc qu'après vu
l'animé rqra nique sur ce coup là c'est
là que c'est surprenant kramnik choisi
de sacrifier son cavalier 5
donc on voit l'intérêt d'avoir un cavani
centrale il a tout de suite une action
dans le clan adverse alors qu'il n'y en
avait pas sur la case est roi et en plus
ça a libéré aussi la dame pour venir en
âge 5
donc là l'animé kramnik laisse le fou g5
emprise et sacrifie son cavalier sur la
case g6 donc il faut quelques idées bien
sûr avec beaucoup de pression parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de variantes et donc
on voit ce qui va se passer 6 6 puis on
prend donc je crois que c'est pas si je
vais le type pas rendre le fou alors
c'est parce que le tir plusieurs
possibilités il peut gagner une pièce ça
ne va pas justement prendre le cavalier
mais alors voilà souvent vous ça ne va
pas parce que alors ben je crois que ça
va pas si j'ai bien vu en tout cas on
joue cavalier cet échec au rang voilà
donc une combinaison donne quatrième si
les noirs donc les noirs peuvent choisir
de prendre seul cavalier évidemment faut
reprendre pièces de ce qu'on a on vient
de donner les blancs viennent prendre un
pion il faut accepter sacrifices si on
veut pas se retrouver avec un endroit
complètement affaibli et sûrement game
blanc rapide donc il faut il faut
accepter le matériel pour justifier sa
position
si les noirs choisissez de prendre le
fou donc fou prend son protégé par la
dame la dame blanche peut pas prendre
mais là donc jean paul ii bat hier nous
propose tout simplement le coup cavalier
e cet échec au roi avec l'idée que les
noirs seraient obligés de reprendre ce
cavalier par exemple par la dame est
maintenant l'idée c'est que ce cavalier
sortie donc le fou contrôle de nouveau
la case achète et on après cet échec
la dame n'a plus qu'à prendre un set
échec et mat la partie est terminée
donc évidemment le fou blanc n'est pas
tout simplement ne pas prendre un peu
preneur donc je vous le dis n'a plus
d'autre choix que de reprendre ce
cavalier angers 6 voilà qu'après vu
l'animé rqra mikeal à la dame qui est
toujours attaquer le fou qui est
toujours sur la menace d'une prise
angers 5 et 6 la dame bouge prise du qg
5 ça fait deux pièces de moins
il faut absolument que vladimir kramnik
est prévu quelque chose dans cette
position alors qu'a prévu le troisième
joueur mondial
dans cette position un court encore
surprenant fou en d3 prend le pion g6
deuxième circuit fils de pièces les
blancs donnent un deuxième four elle
fait une deuxième pièce après le
cavalier maintenant le foot bien sûr
sacrifier contre un pion avec une menace
immédiate très forte
oui puisque il s'agit pour les blancs
lattes de menacer d'un proche cet échec
et mat
ainsi les noirs ne font rien donc est ce
que je vois loti a beaucoup de choix
dans cette position ilan est peut-être
bon d'abord en prenant on voit tout de
suite ce qui va se passer entre nous
donc si si le pion prend le fou alors
d'apprendre pions d'impression des
chercheurs ils auront ensuite la dame
vient h6 leroy reviendrait en j'évite
d'en manger six matchs ou non sachant
plus très chic perpétuer le lecteur peut
tuer donc ce serait pas forcément une
mauvaise opération pour les noirs
meilleur non mais pour les blancs non
plus parce qu'ils sont une chronique
c'est la dernière ronde du tournoi
chronique était en tête du tournoi et il
se contente de la porte au nez
alors ça pourrait effectivement être
l'idée de bannir trad x et non pas de
gagner la partie mais de faire une nulle
rapide par un échec perpétuelle qui lui
assure le gain du tournoi
alors on va voir si c'est effectivement
l'idée de la lumière peut-être que les
noirs vous pouvez essayer
des variantes de gagner peut jouer
peut-être par exemple tour f 7 mais bon
voilà tout 4 vous prendre alors les deux
tours et sète ce serait de protéger le
pion à vii
mais les blancs pour refaire fou prendre
tour avec échec protégé par la dame
récupère la toux mais déjà les blancs ou
un avantage matériel important
puisqu'ils récupérer leurs pièces
sacrifier et même mieux puisque ce
serait une tour contre en cavalier le
travail qui a été donnée seraient
récupérés par la tour plus de pions
davantage seraient considérables votre
cul qui ne va pas c'est jouer cavalier
ici pour protéger le pion et empêcher le
matin alors que m6 avait l'avantagé de
contrôler la qualité est donc sûr d'un
point elle c'est évidemment lecavalier
pourrait reprendre
malheureusement effectivement f6 le
cavaly tout simplement sur le prenable
par les changes là et après la reprise
pour les noirs la dame pénétrerez un set
avec un matt rapidement votre avis donc
je le tiens n'a pas d'autre choix que
d'accepter le deuxième sacrifice de
pièces de vladimir kramnik par le coup
simple h pranger 6 et l'a donc la
nivelle kramnik poursuit son idée d'un
projet 6 échec au roi est la leur on en
a pas d'autre solution que d'aller en a
je suit alors le roi noir est
complètement dénudée par contre le
matériel blanc pour attaquer très
limités ils ont juste cavaliers fou et
très rapidement les noirs pourraient se
regrouper vite pour défendre leurs
droits
donc il faut que les blancs montrent une
attaque très rapide s'ils veulent
espérer gagner la partie
bon il faut calculer puisque
effectivement après 3h 8 alors moi j'ai
vite on a envie quand même d'essayer 18e
coup des noirs donc chronique a dû
réfléchir à divers coubon il ya un coût
qui est évident pour les pour les blancs
c'est évidemment c'est tour des 3 à leur
tour on peut se demander effectivement
que ce que viendrait faire ce tour en d3
mais l'idée tout simplement
effectivement état serait d'amener cette
tour pour moi ici dans as 3 avec un matt
tout de suite qui serait immédiat donc
il peut être un coup très très fort et
effectivement c'est le coût que va alors
voir jouer tout de suite mais que va
jouer mercredi qui choisit d'abord de
faire une dame échec en h5 sur l'euro a
ensuite droit viennent donc en g8 n'est
plus aussi venir angers7
mais le fou aurait pu rentrer dans la
bataille donc ça aurait été très
dangereux
je crois même que les blancs aura gagné
la partie simone noir si les noirs
étaient venus en g7 avec francis on se
convainc assez rapidement que les blancs
peuvent gagner la partie
donc là maintenant cramique revient à
angers 6 donc il répète les coûts pour
l'instant puisqu'il vient de faire déjà
cet échec et leur fait donc qui propose
implicitement déjà de répéter les coups
oui il a le droit puisque donc il faut
que des coûts se répéter trois fois pour
que la partie soit nul donc il peut un
peu peut-être ça dépend des moments
peut-être gagner du temps bien
voir faire un petit peu marine et son
adversaire oui c'est ce qui est dans une
situation délicate bien sûr les noirs ne
peut espérer que le match ne souvent
effectivement quand on a une attaque on
dépense beaucoup de temps et il arrive
souvent qu'on répète les coups comme ça
d' attaques dont on sait que la réponse
est fort c'est tout simplement pour se
donner un peu de temps de réflexion
on respire un petit peu la roi en h vide
donc forcé donc je vais le titre ne peut
pas faire autre chose que de remettre
son roi en la fuite et la voilà ça y est
la démocratique propose l'idée qu'on
avait évoqué tout à l'heure la tour
vient en renfort pour essayer d'attaquer
l'euro à dire ça à l'air très très fort
puisque la menace est tout simplement
une tour atx trois échecs et mat
en un coup mais a joué les hôtes évident
avait prévu tout ça depuis le départ et
il joue un coup de défense et qui est
aussi un coup d' attaque tout simplement
il prend le fou en gsm avec l'idée que
sur maintenant tourage 3 il reste le
couffo h4 protégeant le roi et ce fonds
serait protégé par la dame
ça permettrait au noir après même si les
blancs essayé d'attaquer d'arriver à se
protéger des diverses menaces alors on
va voir d'ailleurs ce que fait quand
même vladimir kramnik échec au roi
je le tiens n'a pas d'autre choix que de
mettre son fou sur la case h4
d'anguilles à plusieurs et la voilà
alors on va avant de voir sur le coup
suivant donc on est au trou noir 22 sous
h4 et là on peut se demander si les
blancs ont pas moyen de
de continuer la taca lorsqu'il faut
noter quand même c'est que les blancs
ont déjà donné deux pièces deux pièces
entières donc trois pions pour trois
pions eux
est-ce que alors par exemple moi je sais
pas je suis maginez le coup simple g2 g3
ses deux premiers coups au visage et qui
menace tout reprend fou avec échecs et
les noirs seraient obligés de donner la
dame
alors est-ce que les sur le coup j'ai de
g3 est ce que les noirs aurait une
possibilité de défense c'est là où il
faut se poser la question
ces salaires crucial effectivement sur
g3 il faut je crois qu'il me dise ce
serait le coup peut-être cavaliers en f4
imaginons la g2 g3 et noir pourrait
jouer le coup cavaliers 4 avec l'idée
que si évidemment les blancs prennent
non mais on ajouta mais le fou le fonds
ne serait plus attaquées et si si les
cils noirs prenez le fourrage 4 on
pourrait apprendre avec la dame
oui mais sur quel la dame blanche sur
sur g3 donc g2 g3 on a tous reproches 4
protégé par le congé doit obliger les
noirs donner leurs dames d'empreintes 4
avec un grand h 4 alors après cavaliers
f4 donc g2 g3 je sais pas je propose par
exemple qu'avec kaka un jour damas six
dans machiste avec échec le roi sera
obligé de venir en j'ai vite
oui et puis maintenant on peut prendre
deux ans maintenant on va le protéger
par l'adama oui la dame ne serait plus
attaquées dans le cavalier on pourrait
prendre le pouvoir ne peut prendre le
fouet la situation des noirs
et très agréable délicate alors est-ce
que
est ce que les noirs d'autres
possibilités sur ce coup g2 g3 des
premières questions qui se pose c'est de
savoir
difficile de voir des défenses
effectivement efficace bollaert ce coup
là très fort donc c'est pas évident de
trouver trouver un coup de défense
ouais
il faudrait analyser ça correctement
mais on se demande comment s est passé
le coup ça a l'air sa nature elle a
l'air naturel donné la dame c'est pas
possible
apparemment ce que j'ai regardé en
premier parce que j'aurai la dame comme
trois pièces après lorsqu'il faut noter
quand même à la basse et que kramnik est
sûre il ya des complications survenant
sur mon équipe de france a en fait
qu'ils sont c'est compliqué peut-être
c'est ça en fait l'idée la première
c'est après g3 de jouer quand même car
9,4 donné à ça parce qu'il faut jouer
mais en tout cas on va donner la dame
sur sa nature tournoi s'est retrouvé
dans une position où on va avoir
on va avoir trois pièces pour la dame
donc on aurait des pieds en moins mais
des pièces active générant une faune ont
pris la tour on se retrouverait avec
tours cavaliers dames contre 3 pièces
ici qui seront équivalents la dame
les deux tours qui contrebalance aurait
suffisamment se fous cavés donc en fait
matériellement parlant à 19 heures sont
capables de prendre éventuellement cc
c'est vrai je crois que c'est cette
défense donc c'est la dépense logique
c'est simplement de sacrifie la dame
mais le matériel qui reste est suffisant
pour continuer largement une partie très
encore très tendue donc on peut noter
que kramnik non plus n'a pas forcément
envie de se casser la tête pour gagner
puisque le idée en tête du tournoi il
sait que la partie nulle lui assure le
gain du tournoi donc ça je voulu montrer
aussi cette partie pour ça c'est que les
blancs peuvent se contenter de faire nul
et c'est finalement ce que va choisir
l'avenir kramnik puisqu'il va proposer
quelque chose d'assez jolie aux échecs
qui arrive
assez fréquemment c'est ce qu'on appelle
un échec perpétuelle vladimir kramnik
joue le coup 23 damage six échecs les
noirs dans d'autres solutions que de
venir en g8 avec le roi et l'annuaire
kramnik rejoue le coup d'objets 6 et
propose partie nulle puisque les noirs
ne peuvent pas empêcher les blancs de
faire un échec ainsi perpétuelle
permettant donc de répéter indéfiniment
la position et donc de forcer en fait la
partie nulle assurant ainsi le guen pour
les blancs sans chercher à voir si le
coup g2 g3 par exemple aurait pu leur
permettre de garder de gagner la partie
on gagne le tournoi surtout bien sûr
voilà un petit peu de cette cette partie
une belle attaque très intéressante
c'est ce alors la grande pour des
joueurs qui aiment la théorie des jeux
d'échecs il faut regarder cette partie
pour savoir si les blancs ont la
possibilité de continuer cette attaque
est très jolie qui était bien mené et
qui est peut-être gagnante pour les
blancs on sait pas mais en tout cas
difficile à analyser
en tout cas les blancs au moins la
partie nulle ce qu'a démontré l'animé
rqra mik
voilà donc une jolie partie un joli
thème l'échec perpétuelle de villes
allemandes un très fort joueur avec il
faut dire que mondiale vladimir kramnik
il faut dire que dans l'autre partie
puisqu'il est dans ce tournoi qui est
tournoi mélodies albert les deux joueurs
sur un homme de foi une foi aveugle et
une fois un parti rapidement à une fois
sans regarder l'échiquier à la veuve
complètement qu'en fait ils sont devant
un écran de l'ordinateur
chacun son ordinateur devant lui l'écran
est évident il ya aucune pièce et il
manipule avec leur souris et le
déplacement des pièces non puisque c'est
qu'un exercice de haut vol ait tout à
fait donc il ya très peu de spectateurs
dans ce tournoi bon puisque c'est un
tournoi presque privé à monaco et donc
c'est un spectacle étonnant les tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde qui sont
presque tous parce que quelques bornes
de plat et donc qu'ils sont réunis là
dans un tournoi où et quand on les voit
tous les deux le profane diwan de
joueurs devant un écran vide mais qui
manipulent les furies pendant une
pendant des heures c'est très étrange et
d'ailleurs je crois que christian losson
qu'est rédacteur en chef de la partie
sport de libération avait fait l'article
l'année dernière lors du tour à monaco
justement sur le jeu l aveugle une très
belle article je pas si on peut le
retrouver sur la version en ligne de
libération s'il est encore disponible
mais c'était un article il valait le
coup d'oeil et qui était très
intéressant
donc à l'occasion je demande de série de
ce tournoi de mon art on est donc dans
les deux parties il faut dire que j'ai
de la deuxième partie a été également
nulle et également sur effectués oui
entre les deux joueurs encore en échec
les deux cinémas deuxième donc où cette
fois ci les blancs ou les noirs qui
redéfinissent inhabituel je crois que
ces deux fois un crabe mick fanning avec
les noirs d'accord donc c'est un endroit
de la partie nulle part scheckter pénale
voilà donc on arrive donc à la fin de
cette émission l'actualité aussi d'eux
mêmes pour vous c'est une rencontre avec
anatoli karpov puisque anatoli karpov et
en france
à gonfreville dans quoi une grande fête
des échecs qui se prépare à gonfreville
qui se situe exactement quand tu revis
de 7 à côté du havre et donc c'est après
demain
oui tu eu les cartes peuvent pas jouer
en simultané
donc le championnant de festival le
chant que champion officiel qui risque
de ne pas défendre son titre à las vegas
est ce que ce qu'il dit en tout cas
enfin on verra et donc il sera
gonfreville dans le cadre d'un festival
où il ya beaucoup de choses puisqu'il ya
aussi la nationale
c'est à dire des meilleurs clubs
français qui sont opposés et puis un
tournoi open
et puis entendent remettre après donc
beaucoup d'actualité chicken je crois
que c'est un anniversaire un bon produit
voilà c'est les cinquantenaires le
cinquantenaire du club
c'est ça de
que de la ville franks et du club voilà
donc une grande fête des échecs avec la
présence d'alain polikarpov donc si vous
êtes war oui mais il faut aller voir le
champion du monde officiel anatoly
karpov c'est comme une légende des
échecs c'est vraiment très très grand
monsieur tout à fait extraordinaire qui
va donner donc une simultanée contre
combien de personnes il va jouer 30
joueurs j'ai trente joueurs à la fois et
si vous avez l'occasion d'aller voir
allez-y c'est un homme tout à fait
agréable au contact facile et d'une
quand on aime les échecs c'est
évidemment un grand grand plaisir à
chaque fois de devoir de voir l'un d'eux
lui car pour jouer
évidemment il est toujours là et la
passion intacte des échecs
il n'est pas toujours sans arrêt en
train de regarder les parties d'un alizé
l'ex ouais t'as fait ça
des toujours il est toujours très
amoureux du jeu ils continuent à faire
la publicité du jeu en participant comme
ça des événements couramment et souvent
en france d'ailleurs cette année on l'a
vu on leur fait qu'il parle l'un d'eux
mêmes pour jouer un dos hermanas le toit
de sermaize près de séville en espagne
où un grand la plupart des joueurs du
monde et meilleur joueur du monde sont
là par kasparov et si on va aussi et
shirov est à bourbourg donc qu'aux non
plus d'ailleurs n'est pas là oui on
retrouvait le pays riches qui est la
vedette de cette année numéro 5 mondial
qui viennent d'arriver dans le top 10 ce
qui est un petit peu l'inconnu y'aura
chronique qui rament
il y aura un an depuis adam aussi judit
polgar d'un retour ça fait longtemps que
l'on n'a pas vu faire bonne garde dans
les plantes
la première joueuse du monde numéro 16
mondial toutes catégories
la fameuse judit polgar plus grandes
joueuses de tous les temps atos est en
place on espère voir à bordeaux on
travaille on va essayer effectivement de
d'avoir judit polgar à bordeaux ça
serait ça serait vraiment encore un
événement intéressant a évidemment dans
la cité des vins donc voila nous nous
quittons sûr c'est sur cette actualité
avec aujourd'hui donc la présence du
président de la fédération française sur
diagonale et la semaine prochaine c'est
le jeudi 8 avril à 18 heures en direct
sur canal web et sur canal fnac
l'interview l'entrevue des quatre
champions invitée au grand prix de
bordeaux en direct avec donc shirov
l'écho bauer et précis n'est donc pas de
diagonale spécial si ce n'est certes
retransmission exclusive canal web et
dans deux semaines un spécial grand prix
de bordeaux avec un montage tout
spécialement effectué pour pour canal
web depuis bordeaux
merci de nous avoir suivi et à la
prochaine fois
m